the release of IBM cloud data security
broker the third generation of IBM db2
warehouse and the launch of Microsoft
365 backup as a service all on this
episode of IBM Tech now what's up y'all
my name is Ian and I am back to bring
you the latest and greatest news and
announcements about IBM technology
kick things off this week let's take a
look at IBM cloud data security broker a
new Cloud security solution that can be
used to achieve field level encryption
masking and tokenization
it's based on Innovative architecture
where a broker sits between an
application and a data store to achieve
data security seamlessly this allows
businesses to encrypt mask de-identify
or tokenize sensitive data without
changing application code it even does
so while supporting customer managed
encryption Keys either a bring your own
key or a keep your own key model
data security broker consists of two
major components data security broker
manager which is a centralized
administrative console for the
configuration and management of data
protection policies and data security
broker Shield which is a reverse proxy
technology that is in the customer's
control and performs encryption
decryption tokenization masking and
access control functions for each data
source
data security broker is now available as
beta on IBM Cloud to learn more check
out the link in the description of this
video
next up I want to talk a bit about how
we're taking a different approach to
cloud data warehousing with the third
generation of IBM db2 Warehouse
data warehouses are mission critical
assets for your business to make quick
real-time decisions but analyzing
massive quantities of data has always
been expensive that's why we've cost
optimized the third generation of our
cloud data warehouse for the always-on
mission critical Analytics workloads we
use inexpensive Cloud native object
storage to significantly reduce your
storage costs while improving
performance over traditional block
storage based deployments once you're up
and running you have full control over
how and when you choose to scale the new
IBM db2 Warehouse completely decouples
storage and compute allowing you to
scale compute separately from the
storage tier
we're also introducing the ability to
catalog ingest query and share using a
variety of open table and data formats
such as Iceberg parquet Json and more to
learn more about the third generation of
IBM db2 Warehouse hit the link below
to wrap things up we recently launched
the Microsoft 365 backup as a service
offering on the IBM Cloud Marketplace
the Strategic partnership between IBM
and storage pipe offers an easy way to
protect business critical Microsoft 365
information
the Futures Cloud to Cloud backup and
policy compliance and Disaster Recovery
requirements essentially M365 backup as
a service prevents you from losing
access and control over 365 data
ensuring it is always hyper available
and protected
to learn more about how to protect your
Microsoft 365 data hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now